so good afternoon and welcome everyone
to the first in a new series of virtual
talk CFR is hosting which we hope will
spotlight how research from across the
Academy from computer science population
in public health economics and
anthropology will be used as the basis
for evidence informed decision making
globally as government's begin planning
how best to open shuttered economies in
the wake of kovat 19 if you're not
familiar with us CFR is a Canadian based
global charitable organization that
convenes extraordinary minds to address
the most important questions facing
science and humanity like many others
across the globe CFR is pivoted quickly
to take action on covin 19 launching
many new projects and initiatives much
of which we hope to highlight through
this series my name is Rachel Parker I
am senior director of research at CFR
and it is my distinct pleasure to
introduce you to Professor Tom McDade
Tom is a professor of biological
anthropology at Northwestern University
and a fellow and CFR's child and brain
development program his research is
focused on the dynamic
interrelationships across and between
society biology and health over the life
course tom is particularly interested in
the impact of stress on the human immune
system he will be telling us more about
an approach he is developing for
community screaming for Cova 19 before
we begin today's session will last
approximately 30 minutes I will be
taking advantage of my position as chair
to ask Tom the first few questions about
his work before opening it up to
questions from participants online if
you have a question you can use the Q&A
function to submit one we ask that you
not use the chat function to submit
questions lastly this session is being
recorded and will be available on CFR's
website so without further ado Tom it's
a pleasure to have a chance to talk to
you today about some new work that you
started some campuses first announced
closure it's just a few short weeks ago
though it seems quite longer than that
first for everyone watching at home who
may not be familiar already what is
antibody testing and why is it important
for understanding kovat xix right well
thanks first Rachel thanks for having me
it's nice to see you and I'm
disappointed we don't get to meet in
person like we usually do as part of our
CFR group
let's pleasure to be coming here with
the be here
you in for my home office here in
Evanston Illinois and as you said we've
been working on a an antibody test for
kovat for the past few weeks and so why
is this important so antibody testing is
distinct from PCR testing and so there's
a lot of talk about testing how we test
for KOed how we test for exposure and
deficiencies in the testing
infrastructure particularly United
States where just the availability of
tests has been very has been stored I
lacking so a PCR test is a direct test
for the virus itself and you've probably
heard a lot of talk about the nasal
pharyngeal swab so we put a swab up a
suspected person cases nose and you pull
it out and you put in a solution and use
PCR which is a molecular mechanism to
directly detect the presence of the
virus there's an alternative approach
called serological testing or antibody
testing and then that's what were
pursuing and what that does is it takes
advantage of the fact that your body's
immune system responds to the virus
subsequent to exposure and one of the
things that our immune system does is
produce antibodies against the virus or
any pathogen that our body's experience
and so we could take advantage in the
lab of the incredible specificity of a
particular antibody against the corona
virus and we can pull out the antibodies
that are specific to corona virus and
detect their presence or absence in an
individual and so this is very useful
because for color reasons clinically it
may be useful because there's a fair
degree of false negative reporting with
PCR testing in the sense that if you
become ill and your physician suspects
that you may have Co it and you get
tested there's a certain proportion of
tests that actually come back negative
and that's because the the expression of
the virus is transient you can become
infected have the virus in your body and
then your immune system can start to
sort of you know tamp it down and
control the infection but you still are
suffering from : from the symptoms of
that and that the illness that that
still requires clinical treatment but
the PCR tests can come back negative so
you can test for antibodies to go a
class of and wise called IgM antibodies
in that sort of clinical acute phase
of infection most of the applications
other people are talking about is with a
class of immunoglobulins or antibodies
called IgG these these antibodies come
online one to two weeks after an
infection and they last a long time in
your bloodstream months to years so we
can detect whether someone has been
infected with corona virus even if they
didn't have any symptoms or even if they
had mild symptoms and then we're not
referred to a clinic or hospital for
actual pcr based testing so it's sort of
like it's a clue for the detective work
of figuring out where is the virus where
has a spread and it's a particularly
important right now because our
understanding of the epidemic and of the
pathophysiology of kovat is based almost
exclusively on research really sick
people who are in the hospital but as we
all know this is a credit as a spreading
through the community relatively rapidly
and easily and so there are a lot of
cases a lot of mild cases and a lot of
cases where people are not actually
expressing symptoms the only way to get
access to that information is to test
those people and detect whether they
have had antibodies for the virus so it
provides clues to the distribution of
the disease and it's spread in the
community and I think this is really
important because I think we have we
have a denominator problem here we have
or testing for cases and diagnosing
cases of coke but but only with limited
testing infrastructure and we're only
testing a limited number of people so we
don't actually know the true number of
cases out there and that affects our
calculation of case fatality rates the
case affects estimates of needs for
critical healthcare infrastructure like
ventilators and ICUs and physicians and
nurses and things like that
so it's a pretty important basic syrup
prevalence data that is lacking and
antibody testing can really help with
that thanks very much are there any
major disadvantages to this sort of
antibody testing it's very complementary
to the PCR testing so the PCR testing is
important acutely to identify people
with infection it's actually also
potentially very important for
preventing the spread of infection if we
could roll out PCR testing among more
people who might be infectious at the
early stage of infection so this is the
piece
testings important in that regard the
antibody testing is important for that
sort of post hoc detective work there
are two potential downsides to antibody
testing one is its application and so we
don't know exactly the extent to which
being exposed to Cova and having
antibodies against it confers immunity
moving forward there's a lot of really
important research on that topic
happening right now but just because you
test positive for kovat antibodies right
now does not mean that you cannot get it
again it's entirely possible well we
just don't happen to have an answer for
that so that's important so we don't
want to overreach in terms of our
assumptions of what a positive test
means the second is that there's
actually been a lot of talk and my
critique recently about the rollout of
antibody testing and high rates of false
positive results meaning that you tell
someone that they have been exposed to
corona virus when in fact they have and
that's a dangerous position to be in we
don't want people walking around with a
false sense of security feeling like
they're immune to the disease when in
fact they're not and this is because the
rollout of the lotta antibody tests has
been based on point of care lateral flow
immunoassays so these are these are
little cartridges right here I can show
you
you probably many of you watching have
seen pictures of this in the news it
looks like a little pregnancy test and
what you do is you take a Knick of a
drop of blood from a Knick of the finger
and you put it in the cassette and the
blood flows down and a line emerges if
you're positive for the antibodies so
it's it's a nice test in the sense that
it can be readily implemented just with
a drop of blood from their finger but
the accuracy is not as high as a lab
based test and it's also just
qualitative it's just a yes/no answer as
it turns out because there are such high
demand for these tests over the past
month a lot of companies have been
rolling out these tests without the
proper take proper vetting by the
authorities for quality and a lot of
sort of cutting corners in terms of
quality control so they're allowed its
tests out there that just don't perform
well and that's that's been a bit of a
problem the alternative approach the
antibody testing is to draw blood - like
you do when you get a physical you
phlebotomist draws blood from a vein in
the arm and they take the blood of the
lab and they test
with what's called a enzyme immunoassay
or Liza and that's highly accurate and
it's quantitative the problem there is
that when you're asking people to stay
at home it's not a great idea to ask
them to then go to the clinic to have
their blood drawn so it's harder to
access that information when because of
the requirement for collecting venous
blood the requirement to collect venous
blood also puts a lot of pressure on the
healthcare infrastructure which is
already overtaxed right so we need
personal protective gear for the people
drawing the blood you need to take a
couple animus or a nurse away from some
other critical activity in order to the
draw the play so there are limitations
that are in terms of how antibody
testing can roll out if it's based on
venous blood so what we've done and the
method that that we shared with you a
bit earlier is we've done something that
sort of combines the advantages of both
approaches we use finger stick blood a
couple of drops of blood from a simple
finger stick but we've put it on a piece
of paper like this this is called a
filter paper a protein saver card and
it's widely used to collect blood from
babies in hospitals all around North
America and the babies have the blood
screening for congenital metabolic
disorders in my research for the past 20
years I've been using this as a way to
get blood from people all over the world
it's relatively expensive you know once
you collect the blood you can fold it up
and send it in the mail so what we've
been doing in my lab is developing an
antibody test based on this collection
method so a person can collect the
sample send it to us back in the lab and
then in the lab we have an enzyme
immunoassay that performs at the same
level that a serum based test would so
we take advantages of the the ability to
collect in the home the convenience is
there with the precision that's possible
in the lab so sort of bridges those two
perspectives so that raises a question
for me how did you develop this you've
mentioned that you're working on it in
the lab it is in campus closed yeah so
our campus closed in mid-march and that
was a campus and also the state of
Illinois the governor has been very
proactive with shelter-in-place quarters
so Campus was basically closed and so I
you know for a couple weeks I was
working at home but I
yeah antibody testing started to
percolate up and a lot of people were
talking about it and I realized that my
lab had all the equipment we needed to
develop an antibody test we've developed
previous antibody tests in these filter
papers for cars whose drive let's go out
the carts before and so I started to
like some colleagues at the medical
school about whether we should work up a
method and they were they were keen to
do this for clinical testing of
healthcare workers using blood samples
venous blood samples serum and plasma so
I struck up a conversation and
ultimately collaboration with them where
we in parallel developed a method one
for serum one for dried blood spots
which I led in my lab so I had to go
campuses basically shut down so I had to
get special permission to allow myself
to be in in my lab which was fine there
was no one else there so it's easy to
work safely and - there were two major
challenges as though once I had gotten a
lab one was that I had a bunch of
supplies that I needed and there was no
mail service to campus there was one
central facility turns out all my stuff
was going there as well as a different
facility so I had to go all over campus
at various points and times to get the
things that I needed to work up the
assay and then the second is that I
needed samples so I started through
word-of-mouth friends and family with a
an approval from our institution or
review or
started collecting these finger stick
blood samples from people who had tested
positive for the past few weeks and then
I got some samples from people who had
tested negative and then I also needed
some blood workup some materials to
develop the method and usually in the
lab my lab technician and I will draw
blood from each other but he was working
from home and I was working from home in
the lab and so I brought the blood
collection supplies home and drew my
wife's blood around the dining room
table as a science exercise for the kids
one day which she was she wasn't
thrilled about it but I did it alright
job and so with that blood and those
supplies in place I was able to get into
the lab and develop the method and it
looks really good we have an initial
validation that we've completed we're
continuing to collect more samples but
we're looking to scale up the
application of the method pretty soon
how has your work as an anthropologist
prepared you to conduct work on antibody
thing well so I'm an anthropologist but
a particular flavor of anthropologists
and most people when they maybe you're
here by my work they're like oh that's
something anthropology I remember from
college I'm a biological anthropologist
and within biological anthropology
there's a subfield called human biology
and that's that's my area and as human
biologists were primarily interested in
understanding how people live and where
they live how that affects their
physiology how that affects their growth
and development and ultimately their
health I came you know Perlas perilously
close to going to medical school so I
have a background in interest in biology
and health but I in graduate school I
was interested primarily in everyday
people normal people living their
everyday lives and how people in
different parts of the world where they
live and how they live affects their
physiology and particularly I have an
interest in inflammation and so I've
conducted research on inflammation in
remote areas of Ecuador Bolivia Samoa
the Philippines Kenya and for me I'm if
I'm interested in measuring inflammation
in those kinds of places I have to get
access to blood samples and I can't get
access to blood samples and places like
that with traditional venous blood
collection procedures and so that's why
I early in my career gravitated toward
these dried blood spot techniques
because for about $1 I could get a blood
sample from almost anyone and anywhere
in the world and then I would bring it
back to the lab and then I would do
various analyses that allowed me to
quantify that things I was interested in
so it's really in my orientation is an
anthropologist towards field based
research I'm going to where the people
are that I'm interested in learning for
him rather than relying on them to come
to me
provided a fair amount of required a
fair amount of methodological innovation
and as it turns out in the current
situation those kinds of innovations of
developing methods that allow us to
collect samples from people in their
homes are well suited to addressing the
current current pandemic so I imagine
that you could use your testing method
to identify subgroups thinking about the
populations that you mentioned that
you've studied around the world and say
subgroups for the population who may be
at greater or lower risk is is that
something that you might expand out to
absolutely so with colleagues here in
Chicago actually we're talking about
trying to roll out a study where
we address that question directly so
that there's there's been a lot of
attention in Chicago to the high rate of
mortality among african-american
residents of the city in comparisons
with whites and so why is that why is it
the black residents of our city of dying
at higher rates even though the rate of
infection is is comparable so one of the
ideas we have is to go into communities
that are predominantly african-american
and roll out as antibody tests to just
see what is the distribution of the
virus in these communities are these
people more likely to be exposed or is
the level of exposure the same across
the city but once exposed the course of
the disease is more serious for certain
individuals african-americans in this
case and that suggests a different level
a different type of problem or a
different intervention that might be
needed if you can disentangle level
exposure from the consequences following
exposure so that's just that's just one
example I think there are there are a
lot of very important near-term
scientific and policy questions but I
think the antibody tests will ultimately
be very interesting for research
purposes to allow us to inform responses
to subsequent epidemics so for example
in the United States right now a lot of
different states are have rolled out
different policies to stem the spread of
the virus and many states are starting
to roll back those stay at home orders
and the restrictions on closing
businesses and things like that so we
could if we could get out there pretty
soon and collect samples strategically
from different groups around the United
States we could determine what is the
level of a distribution exposure so far
and if one state opens up earlier than
another state or they had see a
subsequent spread of the virus versus
other states that stay at home more so
we can use it as a way to empirically
evaluate policies that might be used to
inform future responses to stemming the
spread of the virus I think that's one
particularly compelling and important
question that this method could
potentially facilitate so that leads
actually to another question that I had
about how scientists
so you mentioned policymakers and
governments but how high scientists use
antibody testing to better understand
the course of future outbreaks I think
an important question here that I
alluded to earlier is
if you test positive for antibodies
suggesting you were previously exposed
just how immune are you to subsequent
exposures and that's something that will
be worked out in a more clinical setting
hopefully over the next couple months
but once we know what it means to test
positive for an abaya virus we can use
that information if we roll out testing
more widely to model the course of
subsequent epidemics so if we know in
parts of the world that a certain
threshold of immunity has been achieved
then in those contexts the distribution
of the virus will be different when it
comes back so that's an important source
of information for forecasting the
course of future spread of the virus and
future epidemics I also think there's a
set of really important questions that
we aren't really talking about right now
and then that's fine because there are
more pressing matters but and these are
questions that scientists particularly
in our CFR group I think are very well
positioned to help address because many
of us are engaged with longitudinal
research studies where we have
information on people from before the
epidemic in some cases decades before
the epidemic and now we're gonna have
information during and afterward and so
important set of questions there is who
gets infected who gets exposed who gets
infected and once infected who has a
mild case or a case with no symptoms at
all versus who has a severe case that
ends up in hospitalization and
potentially death we're going to have
data genetic data developmental data
behavioral data contextual data that can
help us inform who is differentially
exposed and who is a differential risk
subsequent to exposure I think that's a
really important question we can also
look at who's exposed and what are the
long-term consequences of that I mean
they're obviously there will be some
physical health consequences hopefully
minor but for some individuals an
exposure will lead to some significant
long-term health consequences and then
this is an incredibly stressful time and
there will be mental health consequences
in the long term as well as the short
term so we can say that as well and then
I think the other question is what's
going on with the kids why is it that
children do not seem to be vulnerable to
this infection we know kids get lots of
infections and this one seems to be
passing them by or
maybe they're already exposed and
they're just having mild or asymptomatic
cases that to me is a big question mark
and something I'm really excited about
trying to follow up on and the method
that we have for just using a drop of
blood I think will greatly facilitate
research with kids because it's a lot
easier to get a drop of blood from my
kid than to do penis play thank you so
much Tom for sparing these insights on
you on your work I have so many more
questions I could ask but we are short
on time and I did promise to take a few
questions in the audience so I'm going
to turn to though it's you the first one
you mentioned briefly now that some
states and provinces in Canada and
elsewhere around the world are starting
to open their economies back up that
this could be an opportunity to to use
antibody testing just to figure out
exactly what the denominator was but
this question is actually asking how
might governments use community based
approaches to antibody testing to decide
to open up well that's like that's a
great question and I think that's partly
one of the reasons why there's been a
lot of interest in antibody testing and
the case they immediately comes to mind
is the case of Italy which you know had
a horrible outbreak and is on the
downward slope right now and they're
talking about universal antibody testing
as a way to identify people who can get
back to work safely so I think there is
promise there the problem is as I
alluded to before we don't know that
people who have been exposed and who
have antibodies as evidence of prior
exposure if they're actually
subsequently immune it's likely that
there will be some degree of immunity if
our immune systems respond to those
virus in ways that it hasn't private and
with earlier viruses of this type there
will be some immunity conferred well we
don't know exactly how much immunity
that will be the antibodies that that we
test also don't live forever and they
can change over time so multiple testing
will probably required so I think that's
a good idea and these data ultimately
could be used to inform decisions to
open up but I don't think we're quite
there yet another question from home
asking how you avoid contamination from
the mail or
sources that's a great question and
something that I was a bit worried about
obviously doing this research on my own
in my lab and with my kids and my wife
and everything but a couple of things
first whenever we're in the lab and we
handle any materials that have any
biological substances on them or in them
we just assume they're infected and we
handle them appropriately with the
appropriate personal protective gear and
we have the right facilities in the lab
to handle things safely but the the
thing that makes me feel better about
the enterprise of sending collection
kits to people and having them mail them
back in is there are two things one is
that this is routinely done for newborn
screening programs in North America
where hospitals and clinics will collect
a blood sample from a baby put in a card
and then send it to a centralized
testing facility so this hasn't been
routinely done for the past 40 years and
the reason it can be done safely is that
once the card once blood dries it is not
as infectious so even if you have a
little example that has something
infectious in it once it dries it
virtually all the pathogens are
deactivated furthermore you can't break
and spill the sample because it's dry so
that's one of the reasons why I can be
sent safely and and also there's been
some work that on coronavirus and its
ability to live in different surfaces
and the half-life of the virus itself on
paper cardboard those kinds of surfaces
is quite low so there's evidence to
suggest that just the a day or two of
the virus being on a surface like paper
or cardboard it won't be viable anymore
so we don't you shouldn't have to worry
about that great thank you
another question from home is it
challenging to make sure the positive
results are not from other coronaviruses
that's that's another great question so
this gets at this issue of specificity
and sensitivity or false positive false
negative results and that's a key issue
that we're working on in the lab and
that anyone who wants to do antibody
testing has to work through and there's
a little bit of a trade-off there if you
dial up your test so it reports fewer
false negatives then you're more likely
to report false positives so one of the
things you have to decide is which is
riskier delivering a false positive
result or a false negative
if people are going to assume that
they're conferring that they have some
immunity from a positive antibody test
then you might want to be a little more
conservative out the false positive rate
an advantage of testing in the lab is
that we can test with more precision so
we should be able to have high levels of
sensitivity and specificity or low rates
of false positives and false negative
results and what the thing one of the
things we're doing right now is
collecting a lot more samples from
people who are confirmed positive cases
people who are confirmed negative or
samples that were collected before the
pandemic and we can look at what's sort
of the average level in our test for
people who are confirm negative and then
we want at a safe distance for the pot
to identify a positive case so that's
part of the lab work that we'll be doing
moving forward thanks very much I think
we have time for one last question this
sounds like a great place to end so this
this test sounds almost too good to be
true
it sounds like they should be rolled out
universally what are the rate limiting
steps of making distributing and
analyzing these tests that is a great
question there are some limitations
right so I don't maybe I oversold it
question or thing is too good to be true
but I do think it solves an important
problem of getting samples from people
without asking them to leave their homes
and taxing the healthcare system and
combine that with precision in the lab
so I think it has tremendous possibility
I think there are there are two two
limitations one is that the clinical
testing infrastructure in the United
States and Canada as far as I can tell
is really focused on the collection of
venipuncture blood venous blood and the
machines are optimized for that the
methods are optimized for that so it's
like it's a conservative approach to
testing and sometimes it's hard to talk
people out of that and to think
differently about these kinds of tests
so that's one else'll the second is that
mostly the supplies are readily
available it's not very expensive but
the lab infrastructure is not there so
we would have to ramp up lab capacity my
lab is a research enterprise you know we
could test hundreds of samples a day
with a couple of technicians but the
demand is going to be thousands to tens
of thousands so can we ramp up other
research academic labs to aid in this
effort I think we could that would take
resources and
in effort hospitals and other clinical
high-throughput testing facilities they
have certain machines that can test high
volumes of an above serological tests
with venous blood could those be adapted
to use with the filter paper samples I
think they could but that will take some
imagination and some hard work to
mcallen well that is all we have time
for today
before everyone signs off I'd like to
thank you all for joining us from your
living rooms kitchen counters or home
offices and I'd especially like to thank
Tom McDade for joining us in this
inaugural talk as a reminder this is the
first in a series of live virtual
sessions CFR will be hosting related to
kovin 19 please visit our website see
far dot CA to find out more about this
series and finally Tom we really did
have so many great questions that we we
just can't get to we might see if you
want to do a kind of handwritten
question-and-answer response that we
could post alongside the recording just
to get to a few more parts I'd love to
see the questions we could talk about
next steps and thanks for the
opportunity to share my work appreciate
it nice is here great thanks very much
everyone
so long
you